a New Jersey judge faces calls for his
removal amid nationwide outrage over the
way he handled a rape case the alleged
assault was captured on cell phone video
but the judge declined prosecutors
request to charge the 16 year-old
suspect as an adult in part because the
judge says this teenager came from in
his words a good family
meg Oliver is following this case meg
what's next people are very upset about
this they are good morning to all of you
while an appeals court overturned the
judge's decision warning him about
expressing bias toward privileged
teenagers the case could move to a grand
jury where the teen would be treated as
an adult victim advocates say this is
the latest example of judges seemingly
protecting accused rapists rather than
their alleged victims critics are
slamming New Jersey Judge James traianos
ruling saying he was too lenient toward
his 16 year old boy accused of
assaulting a girl at a party prosecutors
said the teen shared video of the
alleged incident and texted friends
saying when your first time having sex
was rape but Troiano described the
suspect as an Eagle Scout saying he came
from a good family and was doing
extremely well in school CBS News legal
analyst Rickey Clements it is remarkable
in this day and age that a judge could
look at the facts of this case and not
consider this situation a serious enough
crime that would warrant this young man
being tried as an adult the judge also
questioned outloud whether the encounter
was a rape saying rape usually involved
two were more males using a weapon
sometimes in an abandoned house or shed
Triano is now drawing comparisons to
former California Judge Aaron Persky he
sentence Stanford University student
Brock Turner to six months in jail for
assaulting an unconscious woman writing
a prison sentence would have a severe
impact on Turner these kinds of biases
and attitudes are completely
incompatible with serving as a judge
Michelle
Dober led the successful campaign to
recall Persky last year she worries
these rulings could have a chilling
when it comes to reporting similar
crimes decisions like this and
statements like this that favor accused
perpetrators really depress victims
willingness to come forward prosecutors
say they are now assessing their next
steps in talking with the victim and her
family we reached out to the accused
teens attorney but have not yet received
a response we also reached out to judge
toreano a spokesperson for the court
says they have no comment at this time
I'm very fascinated by this judge
because he seems a little out of touch
if if the thinking on his part is that a
rape normally involves two or more
individuals and a weapon in an abandoned
house yeah and his definition of a good
family when somebody says your first
time having sex was rape by Ricky what
do you know about him well we looked
into his background we did not find a
pattern of leniency he is a retired
judge he has called on from time to time
but as Ricky Kleeman pointed out she
hasn't heard words come out of a judge's
Mountain like that since before 1970 Wow
this awful story yeah thank you may